- What would you like to hear a rap about?
- [Man] Self-help book.
- Self-help books, cool.
Any particular type of self-help book that
you want us to focus on?
(audience laughs)
Are you worried about
giving too much away?
(audience laughs)
Like, what to do when you
have a very small penis?
(audience laughs)
What to do when you
have a very large penis.
You know that's cumbersome
as well, isn't it?
(audience laughs)
Well what's that--
Someone else can help you on this one.
I mean, that goes against the rules
of self-help doesn't it?
But someone can comment.
(audience laughs)
Let's get a type of self-help book.
I mean guys we have to
finish at some point, so.
Other area of the room
help 'em out with this.
- [Woman] Loving the planet.
- Loving the planet,
a self-help book?
(audience laughs)
Okay, cool, yeah.
A self-help book to encourage
you to love the planet.
What to do when you do
not love the planet.
I like it, cool.
That's the first suggestion.
We're gonna get four more.
Please don't take as long
giving me them as that did.
Right.
This kind of area here,
what do you want to rap about?
You've had so much thinking time!
(audience laughs)
You better not let me down over here.
- [Man] Elon Musk.
- Elon Musk--
(disagreement noises)
It's been shout out before.
What was that?
- [Audience Member] Mars?
- Mars?
Eh, that's obvious.
C'mon, be fun.
- [Man] You really want Area 51.
- No, I said Area 51
yesterday all the time.
No one fuckin' listens, do they?
(audience laughs)
He was in the bathroom. (laughing)
How do you know?
You were here!
(audience laughs)
Got a little camera!
Eh!
(audience laughs)
I'm gonna accept suggestions
from anywhere in the room.
All right, come on.
We need liter--
We need four more.
A hand up, so polite.
- [Man] Selling timeshares
to hotel guests.
- Selling timeshares to
hotel guests, self-help book
for when you don't love the planet, good.
So far, these are good.
You've made up for it so far.
(audience laughs)
Come on, let's get three more.
- [Man] Mario Kart!
(woman cheers)
- [Another Man] Yeah!
- Mario Kart!
(woman cheers)
Can we have a specific
aspect of Mario Kart
you want that to focus on?
- [Woman] Level one!
- Level one?
Have you ever played Mario Kart, mate?
(audience laughs)
I'm not sure if you're talking about,
you know, like 50cc or Mario Circuit.
You know, okay.
Level one of Mario Kart,
that's what you said.
That's what it's gonna be.
- [Man] Rainbow Road!
- Rainbow--
No, sorry.
That's definitely not level one, mate.
That's impossible!
(audience laughs)
We can all agree the SNES
version's the best one, right?
Um...
- [Audience Member] Fortnite
- Two--
We've got Mario Kart, Fortnite won't--
No.
Two more.
- [Audience Member] Getting
the oil off your garage floor
from your MG that you bought.
- Having a what on the garage floor?
- [Audience Member] Getting
the oil off the floor.
- Getting the oil off your garage floor
from the MG you bought, yes!
This is--
(audience laughs)
(woman cheers)
It's been worth the wait!
'Kay.
There's only gonna be one more, but--
So, we've got self-help books
to teach you how to love
the planet, selling
timeshares to hotel guests,
Mario Kart, but level
one, getting oil off your
garage floor from the MG you bought.
These are amazing!
One final one.
This can be--
(audience member exclaims)
This can be simple if you want, right?
It doesn't have to beat all those.
- [Audience Member] Audiobooks!
- [Audience Member] Princess Diana!
- How do you fly a hot air balloon.
What did you say?
- [Woman] Princess Diana!
- Princess Diana, cool!
How do you fly a hot air balloon
when you are Princess Diana?
That's the question.
(audience laughs and claps)
Okay, those are great suggestions.
We've managed to pull 'em together.
This is gonna be fun.
This, lovely people of the
Comedy Cellar, is gonna be
a freestyle rap.
That is a rap made up on
the spot, based entirely
on those suggestions.
- [Woman] (calls out suggestion)
- It's not written down--
Shut up, um...
(audience laughs)
Where were you when I
needed you at the start?
A freestyle rap!
That's not written, it's
not prepared, it will
never be seen again.
And do not worry, it won't
be anywhere near as bad
as you're expecting. (chuckles)
Thirty year old, privately
educated middle class
white boy to be.
Let's do this.
If you could drop the beat, good sir.
Let's get this shizzle goin' for rizzle.
I'm excited!
(audience laughs)
I'm real excited!
Where to start, where to start.
Maybe with you, 'kay.
♪ I love my new beat! ♪
♪ I've got a goal, yeah! ♪
♪ I've got a quest! ♪
♪ I strive to sell shit to hotel guests! ♪
♪ I'm standin' there ♪
♪ I look self-assured ♪
♪ I've got a nice Bic
Biro on my clipboard! ♪
♪ I say "Hello there!" ♪
♪ I've got wax in my hair ♪
♪ "Hello sir, do you
wanna buy a timeshare?" ♪
♪ Just a little bit of
money in the buildin' ♪
♪ You could sell it later ♪
♪ Make a killing ♪
♪ That's a damn lie ♪
♪ They never will sell ♪
♪ They'll stick with you ♪
♪ Until you go to hell ♪
♪ And then pass down ♪
♪ Your progeny ♪
♪ Or your earlier relations, ♪
♪ Resort fees ♪
♪ Gotta pay them, ♪
♪ You never get it on the market ♪
♪ If you buy it, yeah ♪
♪ Please don't start ♪
♪ It's just a scam,
it's really a swindle. ♪
♪ I wanna go like a big fire ant hill ♪
♪ Burn, shoot it when I
press on the second light ♪
♪ Mario Kart, get a rocket
start, that's right! ♪
♪ When you see the guy in the clouds ♪
♪ Hold up the lights among that crowd ♪
♪ Maybe you're riding as
Bowser or Princess Peach ♪
♪ But which level are we on? ♪
♪ I can't reach past level two ♪
♪ So I am on the easiest ♪
♪ I call it level one. ♪
♪ It doesn't exist, but I make it up ♪
♪ Probably it would
involve the Toad Cup. ♪
♪ Toad Circuit, Mario
Wonder Castle, too. ♪
♪ Not Rainbow Road, that's a hassle to ♪
♪ Stay on the course as you're
dropping off the edges ♪
♪ It's horrible, you plummet
into space from the ledges. ♪
♪ And then they updated it for the Wii ♪
♪ And Nintendo Switch and actually ♪
♪ It's a real time sync ♪
♪ Amazing, that plan there. ♪
♪ I drive badly like Princess Diana. ♪
♪ I'm sorry that I had to do that ♪
♪ If you think in your
mind, go straight back ♪
♪ To 1997 in Paris ♪
♪ Henry, the driver, drove with glee ♪
♪ He was goin' too fast ♪
♪ He felt all the booze ♪
♪ No seat belts in the back were used. ♪
♪ But let me think about
an alternate timeline ♪
♪ Princess Diana could
clear the land mines ♪
♪ From high, yeah! ♪
♪ She's up and floats on
in a hot air balloon ♪
♪ Dropping cluster bombs to
de-charge all the minefields ♪
♪ In the places where they blow
up in the little kids' faces ♪
♪ She pulls the chain ♪
♪ Yeah, look at him! ♪
♪ There's Dodi, they
would save those limbs ♪
♪ From the children ♪
♪ Sadly, the press did kill them ♪
♪ That is what they say, yeah. ♪
♪ I move on and I spill them ♪
♪ The beans I mean, and also oil ♪
♪ Coming from my engine machine. ♪
♪ There was a hole in it! ♪
♪ Jesus, I speak in an irate
tone cause this oil leak ♪
♪ Was comin' out the front ♪
♪ Who the fuck did it? ♪
♪ The guy who sold me the MG Midget. ♪
♪ It's a fast car, only got two seats. ♪
♪ Said that it came, 100% complete ♪
♪ It was replete with turbo chargers ♪
♪ I look inside ♪
♪ Henry is my father ♪
♪ Gets when he watches the news ♪
♪ I'm in the garage ♪
♪ I put down lots of newspaper ♪
♪ The only thing to
absorb it from the floor ♪
♪ If you don't love the planet ♪
♪ You don't adore the Earth ♪
♪ She's a mother, like
James Lovelock said ♪
♪ Gaia prophecy hypothesis ♪
♪ From the head you can
get the book you deserve ♪
♪ A forward written by Greta Thunberg ♪
♪ She'd give you it from the library ♪
♪ And said, "don't ask questions at me. ♪
♪ Look deep inside yourself, ♪
♪ We've gotta preserve the
planet and preserve our health ♪
♪ Like mentally, yeah! ♪
♪ You're a little ♪
♪ Well, Peter, listen
up and read up about ♪
♪ The self-help ♪
♪ Fuck all that stuff inside you ♪
♪ If we don't stop using
all the fossil fuels ♪
♪ We're gonna die, leakin' oil
like the Horizon Deepwater ♪
♪ Or the car that you're buyin'" ♪
♪ Thanks Greta, for the nice book. ♪
♪ You'll save the planet, get
the polar bears off the hook ♪
♪ Yeah! ♪
(audience cheers)